ايضا ربما يجدر الحديث عن المعارك
المحتدمه على المدن المتاخمه للعاصمه
دانياتك ربما ايضا نظهر الصوره هنا احد
المواقع التي سقط فيها ااا عده صواريخ منذ
فتره نتحدث عن المعارك في مار كوافضيفك
تحاول القوات الروسيه اقتحام مدينه
افديفكا وربما
لابد من الاشاره الى ان القوات الروسيه
تتقسم الى القوات الشيشانيه القوات
الافخازيه القوات الخاصه قواتنا رفا في
محور افديفكا تقاتل الفرقه الخامسه عشر
وهي قوات من افخاذ يا جمهوريه افخازيا
المرتبطه في الدلاليه مع روسيا تحاول
اقتحام المدينه بعمليات عسكريه كل يوم لم
تفل هذه المحاولات حتى الان مدينه افديفكا
دخل الجيش الروسي وسيطر على ثلثي المدينه
وسيطر على عده احياء في المناطق الغربيه
من المدينه ويحاول اكمال السيطره على
مدينه مارك بينما ما بين افديفكا ومان
مارنك وهناك بلده همم بربامايسكا بلده
بربمايسكا تقاتل فيها القوات الشيشانيه
وتحاول اقتحامها وتحاول السيطر عليها هذه
المدن كلها متاخمه لمدينه دينيس من
الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه كما تستعر
المعارك في محور باخم والتحاوي القوات
باقر السيطره على المحور الجنوبي من
المدينه بعد السيطره على ايفانوسكا
وكوردوكا وتحاول الدخول هناك قتال شوارع
حرب عنيفه في شوارع المنطقه الجنوبيه بعد
ان اكملت السيطره من المحور الشرقي
والشمالي